[Music]
et caught up with Kevin Hart in New York
City on Saturday at the Tommy John by
Kevin Hart event where he reveals his
wife Anika Parrish is ready to give
birth to their baby boy Kenzo any day
now about the drop my wife sneeze wrong
she'll had that baby right now
Hart who has two children from a
previous marriage adds that he's looking
forward to meeting his little one you
know to have another addition to the
family
especially a boy that last name Hart
lives on it's an amazing thing both of
my kids are excited she's excited that's
the best thing for me that's the biggest
gift that I can ask for nothing else
comes close and while he's excited he
wants his wife to hold Kenzo in there
just a little bit longer she trying to
dance the baby out I told to sit out you
can't come out yet I got two more things
to do and that baby could come out don't
know had his baby well while I'm at
Disney Vic oh I'm running this marathon
don't you do that the 38 year olds
comedian ran the New York City Marathon
on Sunday there's about to go down 26.2
miles and revealed he had one goal for
the 26.2 mile race I don't want any bad
memes out there you know if you get a
cramp
and they catch that picture that's gonna
last forever some I'm trying to keep my
face as strong as possible throughout
this marathon no bad means
that's my mind honor no hey catch me ah
no limbs across the finish line that's
what I'm trying to do
[Music]
you